want to show you now some live pictures
from Vatican City where crowds are
expected to gather in the coming hours
after news of the death of former Pope
Benedict XVI the Vatican has said his
body will be taken to Saint Peter's
Basilica where it will be lying in state
from Monday let's now speak to historian
Alberto otonini who joins us from
Florence in Italy thank you very much
for speaking to us we were somewhat
expecting this news because the current
pope had said that former Pope
Benedict's Health had considerably
deteriorated in the last few weeks I
want to ask you first about the
protocols here because I know that the
Catholic church has very strict
protocols in place after the death of
its leader but what happens with an
ex-pope do the same protocols apply to a
typo
yes probably yes even it's something
very new for the Catholic church and for
the protocol of the Catholic church so
we really don't know exactly what we can
expect but the most possible solution is
to maintain the same protocol that they
use to have with the the ordinary Pope
let's say so probably nothing new in
this respect
Pope Benedict former Pope Benedict in
2013 became the first pope in 620 years
to step down from the role he cited old
age at the time ill health tell us more
about him he was of course a brilliant
scholar and I understand he had a lot of
influence in the Catholic Church what
was his world view
well he was mainly a scholar as you
correctly mentioned mainly a scholar
than a real leader in sense that he was
it was not very comfortable speaking to
a large audience or acting as a
political leader so he maintained this
scholar profile he was a thinker a
philosopher and he liked to maintain
this activity also during the eight
years of his papacy and so his influence
was mainly a an influence of a
philosopher of a theologist more than a
leader and this was well received by
some sections and some groups in the
Catholic Church less well received by
other uh groups in the same Catholic
church but he had somewhat of a mixed
Legacy didn't he after he resigned in
2013 over his handling of the sexual
abuse candle in the Catholic church he
had promised when when he became Pope to
reform he'd apologized to the victims
did any of it happen yeah
yeah
yeah
he was involved not personally of course
but as the head of the Catholic church
so with the very very controversial
issue of sexual abuse and also you may
remember Financial
scandals in the Holy See and so these
probably were among the reasons he
decided to resign to step down because
he realized he was not really the good
the best person to take a responsibility
and and to find a solution to both the
sexual abusive Scandal and also the
financial
issues that arise during his papacy
now if you're just joining us on Al
Jazeera we are covering the death of
former Pope Benedict XVI the Vatican
announced that the pope Emeritus died
Saturday at 9 34 a.m We are talking to
Alberto Tony a historian about this
looking at the legacy of the former Pope
uh you talked about the scandals there
Alberto and his papacy was also prone to
gaffes
um and and Scandals the financial
scandals that you mentioned how how did
he manage the bureaucracy of the Vatican
and and what do you think the Catholic
Church will remember him most for
he was really in great difficulties with
the Vatican bureaucracy he was an
outsider in a sense because as you know
he was of German origin so we he had a
little familiarity with the Roman Church
let's say and so this was one of the
problems and he relied on some Italian
uh Bishops let's say and Cardinals to
help him in this dimension in the
management of the Holy See and the
bureaucracy but this resulted in a very
weak leadership by Benedict and and so
from this perspective his legacy his
legacy was a very difficult one and with
which the the current pope had to cope
during the last nine years yeah the
current going to Pope Paul Francis
himself publicly shared the news of his
predecessor's worsening health a few
days ago what was the relationship like
between the two men because they clearly
had very different World Views
yeah very different background a very
different approach but personally the
relationship among the two were very
very warm very good and and very
sympathetic let's say because they are
both of them are very brilliant persons
and very smart
persons and so these allow them also to
overcome the mutual differences and to
have a very nice personal relations also
during these last years during these
last weeks Pope Francis met more than
once the the Benedict during these last
weeks as far as we know and so from the
personal point of view they were I could
say good friends
thank you very much Alberto tornini for
speaking to us and uh talking to us
there about the legacy of former Pope
Benedict who has died at the Vatican
today at the age of 95 the news was
announced by the Holy See press office a
short while ago saying that the pope
Emeritus died at 9 34 a.m on Saturday
his health had deteriorated considerably
over the last few days with the current
Pope Francis himself sharing the news
about his predecessor's worsening health
and asking the general audience to pray
for him to pray for the pope Emeritus he
was leader Pope Benedict the leader of
the Catholic church for fewer than eight
years resigned in 2013. the first pope
to do so in some 600 years will have
continuing coverage of this throughout
the day here on Al Jazeera as we watch
those live pictures of Vatican City
where crowds are expected to gather
today throughout the afternoon after
hearing the news of Pope uh Benedict's
death